collaps you're welcome Dana my stuff is
all synced you're welcome Mia hi Lexi
and Marcus and Rachel hello
how are you hi hi I have a Lexi and
plushie on my shelf oh cool
I'm gonna stuff Lexi and put him on my
shelf one day
Alexian don't put this in yeah Dana
don't put that in put it in mine I don't
care
all right ass face is here why is your
name ass face I wasn't sure that would
work or not
um
interesting your ass face
hi hello ass face my name's still Wade
sevens you're Mr Wade Mr Wade
why well were you guys playing this uh
outside of our game
I have not no I don't know what you're
talking about record it Whatever It Is
Us uh all right and I don't play this
for fun what do you mean all right okay
good
in fact anyone monitoring my perspective
would see that uh this is an awfully big
jump from the eight months ago episode I
posted yeah like three and a half hours
of footage was completely screwed up by
me
crazy how that happened yeah well I'm
glad it didn't happen that way right
those those are all hypothetical that
would be so unfortunate if that didn't
happen I would be very it would have
sucked man I would have hated to lose
exactly three hours and 29 minutes of
footage
yeah it's good that you didn't I think I
know I think
think the me thank the you yes
am I am I dumb am I am I yeah honestly
or nicely why can I not plant this
guys I learned flag with circle good
coconut tree is what happens in this
game straw extra oh hell yeah I'm
prepared I have shears uh what happens
is we find Island which we passed one we
need to get I think we're at the point
where we need to try to get some animals
and we need to get more Blowfish yeah we
okay but and we need to head to the next
trajectory which if I turn this on
uh we need to go a little bit Southwest
um I have a sale okay turn the sale do
leftish a bit no wait it's good
all right
okay sick that really worked out for me
the sale not yeah don't do that turn the
sale in the same direction as it already
am it would be horrible if you did the
thing that I told you not to do so don't
do that thing hey guys I had a thought
just now and did not at all read this on
the internet and decide to apply it to
our situation you know how we go real
slow uh more sales might help oh that
was not a thing before whoa do you guys
see the thing
yeah are we sailing backwards
a little yeah there's a big island over
there though yeah it's a very big island
yeah it's a ship I see a big ass Island
that we're sailing toward you see a ship
yeah do any of us have net bees for cats
the net to catch the bees to get the
honey Mark I gotta say this is not a
[ __ ]
oh wow guys I'm in I'm in a tizzy I
can't seem to plant cocoa nuts
how do we get you out of this tizzy I
don't know my tizzy's all up in a stizzy
wow don't tell me oh there's a hole in
the boat
watch out ass face that shark just come
out here I was trying to get my giblets
yeah I was trying to get his giblets I
was previously in the water now I'm here
do we have to do something to be able to
plant coconuts look I don't know I was
planting coconuts uh however many months
ago and it's no longer a thing there's a
we're hitting a rock rock rock rock rock
yeah here take some nuts
um see if you can plant him for some
reason
stick them in there I mean that's what
it used to be but it doesn't seem to be
that anymore are you left clicking I ate
it
I see wait no if you don't play coconuts
do you don't you plant seeds I thought
the Coconuts were the seeds
am I crazy Palm seeds
[Laughter]
coconuts or food
yeah we all knew that and thought of it
you silly goose
why are you making that sad
do we have extra food because I'm dying
yeah there's bowls of soup and plants up
here I got chunks of cooked
salmon all right I might have been
slightly exaggerating my state but I I
am need food Well I this my statement
speed stands come up here and eat food
oh vegetable food yeah
thank you you're welcome oh my God
vegetable soup is amazing I know it's
pretty incredible we should we should
make that sometime yeah I know right I
refuse to eat vegetable soup all right
how do we split a stack good question
right click you can right click and move
one at a time yeah I don't know how to
do more than one look there are many
secrets to this game that we will never
understand like what tell me a secret
that will you will never understand once
when I was a kid I trapped a mouse in my
room and we became best friends I don't
understand that was a lie don't worry
okay good all right not to brag but I'm
on the big boat oh wow you got they're
in a hurry I'm on the ship where's the
boat
someone else beat me here who else is
here don't worry guys I'm coming I got a
mechanical part guys
guys hold on wait leave something I got
note I'm trying to bring some food for
us not to starve but you I have food you
silly goose all right okay why are they
talking
I said no from Olaf speak up Olaf I
can't hear you
all of these nuts from all of us here
thank you let it go right all up
hey Wade I'm being murdered are you here
no I left to try to get up oh is it the
is it the possums it's a it's the
squirrely rat I'm here thanks bud the
squirrely rat okay it's that oh I got
there as fast as I could don't worry I
killed him and took his meat good good
excellent you guys aren't gonna leave
anything for me are you there's a whole
bunch of stuff out here Mark don't worry
about it I don't even know how Bob got
past Bob
get past Bob
are you not inside we're up I go inside
now I found it inside guys don't worry I
had to build a scarecrow out so they
wouldn't get up and eat
food
I'm not up I'm down but inside down but
inside if you go all the way to the back
area you can go down and then go in
um me not understand I think I possibly
found the light switch but I'm waiting
I'm giving everyone a chance to catch up
no down the back past the pool down the
back
I can only hope you come to your senses
and follow us
we knew the city was a failure Reuben
why do you always oh it's dark in here
it's a dildo in the pool
why it dark you guys really not gonna
come over
again don't wait wait for Mark I thought
you were Mark I see ass face I just
think I'm sorry hey wait a minute all
right I think that's a compliment I mean
ass face no I'm not because I don't need
you anymore
okay we don't need you oh he left he
left Mark you're on your own I said that
already I left first
I already don't need you I was first
leave what about where he what did that
do what did what do it's dark I know I
pulled a lever
oh it's light here a note maybe never
mind just I crowbarred the door open
don't worry friends all right
they were clearly once rats now grown
into something much more
feel free to help anytime now
mechanical part
oh we've got a bunch of those oh I got
Fish Head stew
head broth oh can I have it yeah broth
you want head broth dude I'll broth you
up
broth me bro dude I'm gonna bro you
brought me dude I'll frothy
oh you got it you got frothy broths you
guys want to be brothed
red key huh red keys
requires one bolt cutter oh didn't we
didn't one of us pick up bolt cutters no
you guys
done I done used it already I found the
door for the Green Key not the other one
whoa got red key
yeah no hey do we have flukey
no oh gas tank we need to make a bomb I
found a door that needs a bomb bottle
sure found their way to the bar okay
that's a military man I thought all of
wood at the very least
watch out there's big rats
hey
look
wait did you just open that door Wade
[Music]
this door's already open
I already explored oh God ow ow ow ow
I'm hearing Mark dyke that's what yeah
there's a lot of owies
hey mechanical part I found one too good
good oh this room has hey bolt cutters
oh we need that
Green Key
oh God I'm stuck these mice really want
me oh my God these guys still are after
me there's so many rats I've got like a
an avalanche of rats what did I do I
went to the dumb Place lighter
hey I found blue key and note Hey ow
I'm just hanging out with you because I
don't know which way we've gone and
which way we haven't ah you fool I am
thank you
spooky blue key
somehow they believe Rank and Prestige
disappeared with solid land no they will
not be allowed look I opened the back
way in oh my mark you can go in the back
door now oh cool great I'm uh definitely
need that wait has Mark been in here is
Mark doing this what am I doing
wouldn't you like to know yes that's why
we asked yes I really would like to know
hey I know
we have four mechanical Parts by the way
anybody seen a card less than five
whoa what the hell
one of those damn rats
oh hey wait I found a rat
right here
oh look at that we annihilated that rat
yeah we annihilated him
hey guys we had the four digit code
apparently I had it yeah
I I opened the thing that you knew
thanks yeah we opened that thing good
job Bob are planning a mutiny I did it
yeah uh oh but look I got this crate
that you guys won't see where even are
you guys a mechanical Bart oh let's blow
it up we're even I do not see your names
where where you had been I don't I've
been where I've been been where had you
where you was wheeze there now use there
now I was there
I see there you are I see hi look
why is there rat sounds there's mini
rats guys we are here we's ears we have
mechanical parts do we make bomb I'll
make bomb we go we go to the basement
and see about it oh basement oh no wait
yes wait no no wait
uh does anyone have room for things yes
no sir yes I'm going to make the
mechanical part thing okay
go Mark the right way you're doing it am
I going the right way not anymore all
right bed sofa knees and toes knees and
toes
I thought I knew the right way Mark but
I don't okay anyway go down again buddy
down again how do you get down again
stairs
oh uh-huh stairs oh all right
oh my God I love that song Keep stinging
it
oh all right it bite me in the dick I
kill it
I don't I don't like that song as much
as much as I thought I did yeah use five
mechanical okay use one like okay I'll
do this I have a bomb
you have a 1x bomb you have a kind of a
car I know where to use it doesn't seem
like the same thing no I know where to
use that come here follow me okay follow
me oh
oh dick
all right it made me kind of sick
oh I guess I'll use the bomb whoa oh
okay
I just ran to open a door
[Music]
but that's fine I did it oh good job
thank you uh yeah here here man I can't
believe I solo accomplished my speed oh
all right I don't have a weapon I need
to make a weapon
all right
I used a cardiac oh I don't have any
rope I can't make a spear I really feel
like we could have done that by hand
teamwork could have done it we don't
oh there was a spear in here there was a
spear in the crane it's perfect how
advantageous wow that is really good
courageous at least despite vocal
opposition the floating all right was
this important for us oh package we did
it we did it we did it
oh we did it string light
boys I can carry it by some things I
mean literally everything in that room
oh okay
uh crate well you could have grabbed I
guess you couldn't have steering wheel
oh hell yeah oh gosh
I thought you boys would like that I did
like that that's a big crate mark on top
of these gloves I don't know if I have
enough uh just not enough uh
lost sushi recipe I can throw
decorations you can use right away if
you have decoration packages you can
just use them yeah I don't have any but
I'm gonna throw away these leftovers uh
wait uh eat those leftovers you'll love
that
I think think think
damn it
uh who got him who got them
leftovers are all yours you enjoy them
cheers wait you have to watch me do it
yeah Cheers Cheers Cheers
actually that was pretty good I'm
totally fine do you think it would be
bad
I they had like a bone sticking out of
it yeah that green and a bone but
apparently it's good for you and somehow
us conquering this place uh made the sun
come out we did it hey we cured the
sickness now we jump in the water that's
a rock
yeah I wouldn't go that way those don't
water made it those things look
different hey I found another mechanical
part do we still need those uh keep keep
it up buddy I'll just give them
something he he needs something you know
yeah you're right distributed guys did
we leave our boat undefended and did the
shark pull it apart no we're fine no I I
dropped the anchor too it dropped the
whole one foot
is destroying our boat oh conveniently
placed stop doing that buddy hey I found
our boat
why did that make you sick our boat does
make me stick though look at it it's an
Abomination wow all right that was
unnecessary would you say it's in a boat
my nation no because that's silly
look what is that okay
oh
that set off Wade silly alarm
we have a net surplus of some cooked
Goods if you guys want them uh and then
I'll get the I'll get the research stuff
done soonish I've got you two new
recipes Mark I don't know if they're new
but they're new to me so here they are
thanks man you used to use the
blueprints in the in the stuff too yeah
actually I'll slam it in right now
recipes go on the recipe boards or
blueprints go on the blues board okay we
have red melon already but I don't know
if we have manganera oh I have a oh I
have a sushi recipe ooh pop it up on the
bird
oh I got another recipe too God damn we
are we are living it mushrooms my Final
Fantasy 15 up in here because we've
discovered a new recipe did you put the
mango Nana recipe up Wade because I got
that too I know I put it in one of the
boxes up there except there was no space
I gotta make space I was busy that day
I'm gonna throw this away then
oh God
it's fine have fun we need my storage
space
I don't know where that came from
oh that's enough my silly alarm wouldn't
anymore
he's just in a musical mood
there's no we can't put wood anywhere we
were so wooded up if we can't put wood
anywhere why is the queen
[Laughter]
uh do we have big chest from Big plastic
I have two big justices new ones yes all
right we are set we're looking very very
pretty I'm gonna begin the process of
lifting anchor
um
I guess it's not a process but anchor
lifted
man he really speeds through the process
I can't believe you just skip right
through the process like that well well
it was very the anchor was burned
is that good bird or bad bird
there's no such thing as good Bird yeah
they don't lay eggs kill them they don't
lay eggs like [ __ ] uh do you need
meat for cooking pot oh
um cooking or uh we've been kind of
doing the meat downstairs for the grill
barbecue we could make the barbecue yeah
there's a fish there's a fish we do have
some mushrooms but uh there's a chest
back here which is like meats you guys
what did we we didn't ask me did you
kill the bird oh I did I got feathers
and bird meat all right cool we need to
make a sweep net we made it sweetness
it's that voice I do guys
classic Bob classic anyway
I just got never gets old oh God why is
that a thing that keeps happening what
people in my community keep saying that
you just got bobbled and I don't know
who invented that but I don't like it
during a game or a stream or something
but I can't say I'm the first person to
ever come up with it you just got Bubba
Bubba bubbled there's nothing on the
other side of this door
dude you got bobbled
there's a surplus of Palm leaves and
wood because I'm starting to actually
Harvest these trees so it's keeping us
pretty well stocked up on all the
the essentials I feel like the
downstairs of this boat is a little uh
inefficient but there's always room for
improvement I agree Mark get on it
thanks tutorial man
you're welcome happy to help I'd be the
worst superhero power
I don't know Memorial man with the power
to guide someone else into the beginning
of their Story I mean it's kind of cool
what if what if it's like you find alien
Tech and you know he can tell you how
anything works so even even cool if I
was gonna make it really lame uh well
I'm
I'm cool we have like nice wooden plank
floors down here except for I messed up
and made this one not nice how do we fix
that uh is it like reinforced or
something I have no idea uh
uh it is you just have to get rid of
this one I think no no no no no no no no
no no well I hope that's right because I
already did but I thought you could
upgrade maybe it was a visual bug maybe
it was upgraded but it wasn't really oh
no I can't I also have no wood and no
plastic so I can in no way help per
usual you put all your plastic into a
thing well I still have no wood even if
I had the plastic there's a thing with a
whole ass load of wood in it use
yourself oh God I love the Eminem song
what use yourself
oh yeah use yourself with the music the
moment
spaghetti spaghetti already
I like this
mom gave me a big daddy
[ __ ] off I killed another oh my God I'm
a one not hit wonder I'm like MC DC no
MC Hammer
mcgs I got there eventually why can't I
put a foundation here what is this about
oh I don't have nails I'm an idiot did
we find the next cool coordinates uh we
need to find animal Islands can I move
one of these okay I'm gonna move one of
these I didn't ask for permission it was
I lost something that was you made good
sir all right thank you literally in the
middle of cooking and we had full legs
on that too late too late now I promote
it he was promoting
all right it looks like we're right
where we have been great excellent yeah
we haven't moved why is there wood in my
face oh look guys I'm trying to expand
the foundation so we can get another
layer upstairs because this is how we
grow as people and as friends
you [ __ ] [ __ ] son of a [ __ ] you
piece of [ __ ]
there we go
hey look got more space I can get even
more trees I'm ready to do my job what
was my job what was that why do I even
invite it to this what do I do
that's a fair question you know thank
you I've been asking myself for years
why am I here why do we not cash in the
steering wheel and the engine blueprint
we did we did we did we did it just
doesn't consume did we yeah we did we
did we did look in your craftables
well I threw one of them into the ocean
now accidentally so wait can I put them
in a recycle machine yes maybe you have
circuit boards we could probably make
that engine right now yeah we could I'm
working on the ship for the most part
but feel free see I need to
oh we need a we need a fuel source if
we're gonna do engines it's kind of the
sticking point there because we need the
b23 not it the bees the B's right we do
need the B I just made a net I made a
sweep net I go catch some if we can go
get the bees
I love bees really yeah they're great
for Gardens and flowers and they do good
things they make honey Honey's delicious
these are pretty cool I'm down for bees
I like bees uh that's fair that's fair
Netflix and bees Wham okay uh our next
objective well we're not even moving so
I'm not gonna worry about that we can
move we can move I can move we can move
oh yeah okay all right
don't worry wait if I read
I lifted that remember that whole thing
no I really didn't uh
raised it anchor up I've gone through
I've gone through three cycles of beat
Harvest since we've sat back here
just so you guys know uh it's fine
that's good then for us good we're going
now which way sir uh let's see we need
to go do south east of if we're going
the direction we're going we need to
turn uh oh wait I have a number I need
to put the new number in are you guiding
us back to the big boat yeah sorry we
need to go real close it's real close we
need to go right towards that thing do
you guys want to go to vasagathan or the
Balboa Islands
which one is the next one I don't know
oh they're both no uh
is the that's where we were was it oh
yeah yeah we need to go Balboa so 7-0 I
forgot 7038
and I'm out of batteries all right good
luck batteries uh copper Ingot and
plastic we should have that yeah we got
copper coming out of our nose holes
right now I have those all right this
battery is still empty can we recharge
it either uh there's no recharger that
you can get much later in the game I
don't have it right now yeah I don't
have it yeah so I'm making the battery
or should I make the battery I sort of
thought you were making it because you
talked about it so much yeah I thought
at that point you had the battery
already what does the battery mean what
do we need plastic and copper oh we have
that we can make a lot of batteries and
I was like good hey guys I made a
battery in the time it took me to talk
about making a battery oh hell yeah
you're doing it
had done that from the start how do I
add raw materials into the thingama box
you have to have it in your hand and
then you walk up and it's all do you
want to put the thing the Beats work oh
they work
I don't know battery in there you just
have to rub it a little bit to turn it
on rub it a little bit
doesn't seem to be working
the rub it a little bit I'm rubbing it
currently presently
it's not turned off I am maybe it needs
more delicate fingers it doesn't want
beats anymore they might have patched
that out okay I turned it on and looking
at this thing which I definitely know
how to read we need to go please
7038 got it 703
eight okay we got new do Straight Ahead
North North North straight forward
nailed it you nailed it
nailed it dude
I Told You So I love you douchebags
I'm guessing I'm trying to sound like
the guy about your fridge remember your
fridge
I don't think this is how you install a
fridge
I referenced it guys oh God are you
talking about our hit podcast uh
distractible
world renowned oh my spear broke now Joe
Rogan approved not really probably that
Joe Rogan disapproved of us Joe Rogan
unaware
does not even know Avid listener I
assume I can only assume yeah because I
don't know so I'm assuming yeah that's
what you do when you don't know
I forgot to drown
[Laughter]
boys just hanging out underwater like oh
wait I forgot to drown
good forecast face
thanks
you know I'm I'm regretting that a
little bit now you did this to yourself
I did I did I know that I'm expecting
your wishes to be called well thanks I
really appreciate it all right guys
thanks for the mug ass face
no I didn't even do that oh wait I did
that yeah you did that that would
involve me doing something look take
credit man I'm having fun but also not
I'm having fun it's like you're me for
an episode
I don't know if that's good or bad like
bad for you no yeah well bad bad for you
too I feel like yeah that's probably
true ah look at all you ass face all the
time it's like you're me
slowly turns into crying yeah how's that
how's the trees going Marky murdering
Generations
you know it
baby what's up there buddy yeah you know
it
is
I saw that you just went right through
what happened
[Applause]
I looked at the ground and the game was
like
space he thought you were on the ground
ass face
oh man uh we are 2 000 meters from our
destination
all right well all right so I smolted
all of our copper what do I do now I
don't know how did you smelt it all we
had like two stacks of them I've been
doing it the whole time we were talking
and not really waiting
I'm gathering a wood like a bow I've
been literally growing wood well I get
it the old-fashioned way wet and Wiggly
[Music]
yeah we're doing good on Plants
eventually I'll make some more I'm gonna
make another extension to the second
floor at some point here I'm gonna put
all the mushrooms in the upstairs area
so you can cook with them if you so
desire Roger thank you for appeasing my
desires uh it's not wrong I am here to I
reorganized your chest I mean bye
more kind of beautiful
said I clicked one button and all of it
I mean I didn't do that it was the god
of war organizations
do this to us oh all right raft
good one it's up and there oh good yes
this is a raft buddy you got it another
round oh wow
wait a solid foundation doesn't take any
more metal
yeah I don't know if it actually does
anything other than Aesthetics
oh no it takes oh it is no you know what
it is you know what Jesus shut up me
okay suck it just shut your damn mouth
you idiot you okay oh God
yes Facebook you didn't have to
oh God I waved his head butted ah can we
can we hear right there's an island in
around yeah I know I see the island and
the raft yeah they're that you were
looking you right he right we go we go
right go right uh we go
right right all right now that's
leadership I can count on you like
political ads well do I have the ad for
you my opponent sucks diddly dick vote
for me what's that sound I got it oh I'm
gonna get it yeah getting good you guys
are waiting for me right you guys are
waiting for me right you guys are
waiting
I have flippers you can't stop me I
didn't do anything to try I I did I yeah
we seem to be going not toward the raft
oh wait Mark listen so I'm sorry I
didn't realize raft is venturing far
away
[Music]
why do we need the rap what are you so
obsessed about her to go swim to it
probably let's do it go swim do it
there's no shark there's no shark right
now there's no shark right now flippies
all right we'll make flippies I guess I
don't know I put the engine down let's
accelerate away all right let's say oh I
had it ready you guys are gonna want
what I just got I bet
[Music]
um
it's a new recipe
coconut beet I can't read but I got it
what's coconut beet I don't know but
I've got it I guys think it's a drink
that involves beets and coconut yeah I'm
gonna put it in this box rather than
where it belongs because I'm helpful are
you sure that's the right word you're
looking for nope
all right guys I'm gonna make all this
goo into wait goo is the final product
I'm gonna leave all this goo as goo guys
don't worry man
I'm fixing all of our problems with the
goo I'm I was hoping for that I was
missing missing all of this goo oh I see
what the deal is man these these pillars
that we made I did not follow the
previous recipe at all what do you mean
I the prescribed I feel like if I take
out one of these pillars it's gonna just
oh my God it's gonna collapse
yeah I feel like I did not do it
correctly yeah but wait what if you put
one in and then take one out yeah you're
probably right that's probably fine yeah
that's fine yeah this I'm yeah what I've
had is fine and if I take it out now it
should be okay
is it okay we're gonna find out it's not
not okay
it was fine
oh God it's first aisle did you know if
you destroy a pillar it could destroy
the floor uh I do know I just learned
that from watching you [ __ ] up all right
well wow I'm glad I could provide a
lesson uh mongos oh an island land hoe
anime land oh yeah
[Applause]
I
also didn't drop anchor uh
on drop anchor or I didn't touch anchor
I can never tell if you're calling me or
not there are not gonna be bees on this
island this island sucks we need to get
to the island that we're navigating to
that's where the bees are at least
there's wood here we need lots of wood
you're right we do need wood no
Mark I have so much wood for your
project oh thank you thank you so much
some plastic and or scrap trees uh I can
for Bob I won't for you mark there's a
shark in the water do you know that I
did not that's interesting can we do we
have what we need to make a shark bait a
shark bait
um oh we don't but I can I have what I
need there we go
I love that song all right I'm shark
baiting here
so that I can go and get all the Harvest
disabled I love them I love that that's
a shirt how is a shark appear again it's
on the ow what are you doing
faded you you're so baited right now bro
it's
baited ass shark is over here eating my
ass can we kill this because I was
chewing on the bait and I hit it because
I thought it was doing on the boat why I
thought it was shooting on the boat that
might be mine I don't know oh it's
really it oh the bait right the right
thing I did right I apologize yeah no I
oh let me out
don't worry if it comes near this bait
Bob I'll make sure to give it the what
can you just let it chew on the bait so
it doesn't eat my ass
how about if we do that what about that
then I don't think that sounds logical
we drink all the water didn't refill it
Mark I I just moved it I'm sorry look
I'm trying to make a ladder so we can go
up and down easily leaving our baits
right you did we got a backup uh uh we
got a back entrance into the uppy stairs
you with the ladder here so you guys
oh
hey did you guys know you drown if you
don't have any oxygen in your lungs that
sounds like a myth yeah come on I just
wanted you know to know because I care
about you drown no I got him shut up
no wow
shut up
I'm just letting this thing chew on your
bait I feel real guilty about it yeah it
feels better your brother's scared away
from the bait so he can go do other
stuff
that'd be fine
if you say so I mean yeah you finished
your baiting it left
it finished it yeah yeah you know like